mind that we could always infer the results of these removed generators thinking of them as observables from the results of all of the other stabilizer
generator observables of the same type so the number of cubits that this code encodes is equal to the total number of
cubits which is 2 * l^2 minus the total number of stabilizer generators in a minimal gener in set which is 2 * l^2 -
1 and that means we can encode 2 cubits I didn't argue by the way that the code space is non-trivial but indeed
it is non-trivial and I'll leave it to you to convince yourself that there's no way to multiply together stabilizer generators in a way that gives us
negative -1 times the identity so that is the Torah code itself and at this point it may not be
clear at all why this code should be good for Quantum error correction it remains for us to analyze it and what we'll find is that it is in
fact a pretty amazing Quantum error correcting code to understand how the Torah code functions as a Quantum error correcting
code we'll Begin by considering different errors and the syndromes that they generate the first thing to note is that
the Tor code is a CSS code because all of our stabilizer generators are either Z or X stabilizer
generators and what that means is that X errors and Z errors can be detected and possibly corrected
separately and in fact there's a simple symmetry between the Z and X stabilizer generators that allows us to analyze X
errors and Z errors in essentially the same way so I'm going to focus on X errors which are possibly detected by Z
stabilizer generators and you can translate everything to Z errors which are possibly detected by the X stabilizer generators using exactly the
same ideas here's a figure illustrating our two Square cubits on the edges of an L
by lattice with periodic boundaries and we can imagine that this is laid out on the surface of a
Taurus at the moment all of the cubits are blue indicating that these are cubits that haven't been affected by
errors so you should imagine that at this point the state of these cubits is in the code space for this
code as I mentioned our Focus will be on X errors and in just a moment we'll use magenta circles to indicate cubits that
have been affected by X errors X errors are detected by Z stabilizer generators which correspond
to tiles in the figure so what we can do is to let White Tiles indicate plus one measurement outcomes or in other words
entries in the syndrome corresponding to that generator while gray tiles will indicate minus one measurement
outcomes you can think of a plus one outcome or in other words a white tile as indicating that the corresponding
stabilizer generator is Happy everything seems to be okay for this generator well a minus one outcome or a gray tile
indicates that the corresponding stabilizer generator is unhappy because obviously an error must have happened to cause this
outcome so at the moment all of our stabilizer generators are happy because no errors have occur now if we think
about a z stabilizer generator all that it's doing is measuring the parity of the 4 cubits that touch the tile with
respect to the standard basis so a plus one outcome doesn't indicate that no X errors have occurred on these four
cubits but rather it indicates that an even number of X errors have occurred whereas a minus one outcome indicates
that an odd number of X errors have occurred so now let's introduce an X error and see what
happens the two Z stabilizer generators corresponding to the tiles that touch this Cubit are now unhappy because this
x error anti-c commutes with both of these generators or equivalently in terms of the standard basis we're now in
a state where both of these sets of four cub bits corresponding to the two tiles have odd parity so that's the effect of a single
X error so if we were to measure this syndrome and we knew or we assumed that just One X error had occurred we'd be
able to easily infer which Cubit had flipped and we could simply flip it back with an xgate now let's see what happens
when we introduce additional X errors and in particular let's see what happens when a second X error occurs on another
Cubit touching one of the gray tiles let's say the gray tile on the top like
this that tile is now happy because two x errors have occurred on the cubits touching this tile and two is even so
these two x errors together commute with the stabilizer generator for this tile another way to say this is that
this second X error has shifted all the standard Bas of states for these four cubits from odd parity back to even
parity the tile to the left of this new X error on the other hand is now unhappy
we can continue this process of adding new X errors and as long as we form a chain of adjacent X errors where adjacent means that the cubits touch the
same tile we'll effectively push this minus1 measurement outcome around and what we find is that we always have
minus one syndrome measurement outcomes at the end points of chains of adjacent errors so we can always detect chains of
adjacent X errors as long as they have end points there could by the way be multiple chains but but we'll come back
to this possibility later it is possible however that we can have a chain of adjacent X errors that
doesn't have n points which is to say that our chain of Errors could form a closed loop so let's add some more errors so
that they form a closed loop like this for instance we now have an even number of X
errors on every tile so every stabilizer generator is now happy and what we found is that Clos
Loops of adjacent X errors are not detected by this code because we obtain the all plus1 syndrome in such a
case so that might seem kind of disappointing in fact we only need four adjacent X errors to form a closed loop
and we're hoping for something better than a distance 4 code however some closed Loops of
adjacent X errors are themselves in the stabilizer remember that we have an X stabilizer generator for each vertex in
the lettuce and if we mult multiply together adjacent X stabilizer generators we can form closed Loops of X
operations such as we have right here for the closed loop that we constructed just a few moments ago so some closed Loops of X errors
like the one that's shown here aren't actually errors at all because they are in the stabilizer so they do nothing at all to the code space there are however
some closed Loops of X errors that are not in the stabilizer and therefore they represent non-trivial errors that go
undetected by the code and there's a pretty simple way to characterize the different types of
loops loops that cross every line in the lattice meaning every vertical line from top to bottom and every horizontal line
from left to right an even number of times are always products of X stabilizer generators that includes the example
shown on the screen as well as Loops that may be much more complicated including the possibility that they cross the periodic boundaries but